Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the Dominic, is I think the country I probably know least about, Uruguay. Uruguay, yes. Even Costa Rica I knew about the kind of, you know, the dinosaur element, the Jurassic World element, but Uruguay, I don't really know anything about it at all. So I'm looking forward to being educated. Excellent, excellent. Well, we'll have a little potted history of Uruguay later in this podcast. Uruguay, of course, the country that won the very first World Cup in 1930, as you'll remember if you listen to our podcast about the history of the World Cup.
感谢您收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要获取每周独家加更节目、无广告收听、系列节目抢先看，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入我们。多米尼克，我觉得我最不了解的国家大概就是乌拉圭了。乌拉圭，是的。连哥斯达黎加我都略知一二，比如恐龙元素、侏罗纪世界元素，但对乌拉圭，我简直是一无所知。所以我很期待能长长见识。太好了，太好了。好吧，我们稍后会在本期播客中为您简要介绍一下乌拉圭的历史。乌拉圭，当然就是那个赢得1930年第一届世界杯的国家，如果你听过我们关于世界杯历史的播客，你肯定还记得。
So I'm not even sure where it is. I know it's Latin America somewhere, South America somewhere. North, South America? Is it? I have a kind of weird blank spot over Uruguay. So Uruguay is nestled between Argentina and Brazil. It is on the east bank of the river Uruguay. And it is across the bay of the river Plate from Buenos Aires.
所以我甚至不确定它在哪里。我知道它在拉丁美洲的某个地方，南美洲的某个地方。北部还是南部美洲？是吗？我对乌拉圭有一种奇怪的盲区。所以，乌拉圭坐落在阿根廷和巴西之间。它位于乌拉圭河的东岸。它与布宜诺斯艾利斯隔着拉普塔河湾相望。
Okay. You see, I thought it was opposite the Caribbean. I'm obviously getting... No, no, no, no. Yeah. I'm parading my ignorance. I will shut up from now on. Uruguay is one of the most European.
好吧。你看，我还以为它正对着加勒比海呢。我显然是在……不，不，不，不。是的。我正在显露自己的无知。我从现在开始闭嘴。乌拉圭是最具欧洲风情的国家之一。
And a lot of people would say the most European of all South American countries. But Tom, we were meant to start with this sort of children's encyclopedia, just sort of standard discussion. Because I wanted to start like a James Bond film with a free creditcredit sequence. How have you haven't ruined it?
很多人会说，它是所有南美国家中最具欧洲风情的。但是，汤姆，我们本该从这种儿童百科全书式的、比较常规的讨论开始的。因为我想像詹姆斯·邦德电影那样，以一个精彩的开场白开局。你怎么没有把它搞砸？
So, listeners, clear your minds. The camera focuses in, and we find ourselves in the suburb of Positos in the city of Montevideo, this great port on the coast of the south atlantic and uh the british ambassador jeffrey jackson is saying goodbye to his wife the date is the 8th of january 1971 so you can picture the scene he's slightly flared trousers no doubt yeah his his wife is in the bath um so she just calls out to him you know have a nice day darling or whatever or whatever. He says, I'm off now. I've got a meeting at the embassy in Montevideo, in the central town. The office will ring when I'm coming home for lunch. So he goes downstairs out of his house.
所以，听众朋友们，清空你们的思绪。镜头聚焦，我们发现自己身处蒙得维的亚市的波西托斯郊区，这座位于南大西洋海岸的伟大港口，英国大使杰弗里·杰克逊正在向他的妻子道别。日期是1971年1月8日，所以你可以想象当时的场景：毫无疑问，他穿着略微喇叭裤的裤子，对吧？他的妻子正在洗澡，所以她只是向他喊道：“祝你今天过得愉快，亲爱的”或者诸如此类的话。他说：“我要出发了。我在蒙得维的亚市中心的使馆有个会议。办公室会在我回家吃午饭时打电话来。”于是他下楼离开了家。
His driver is there with his Daimler. The ambassador gets into his Daimler and he's looking at his watch, Tom, because he's worried that he's got an appointment with a visiting British businessman at 10.15. So they have to hurry. So they're making their way through the streets of Montevideo, this very European looking city in South America. They turn into a particularly narrow street. And at that point, as luck would have it, a red van pulls out and bumps into them. And, you know, Jeffrey Jackson in the back is obviously furious.
他的司机开着戴姆勒汽车在那里等候。大使上了戴姆勒，看着手表，汤姆，因为他担心自己要在10点15分与一位来访的英国商人见面。所以他们必须抓紧时间。于是他们穿过蒙得维的亚的街道，这座南美洲极具欧洲风情的城市。他们拐进了一条特别狭窄的街道。就在这时，真是不凑巧，一辆红色的面包车突然开出来撞了他们。你可以想象，坐在后座的杰弗里·杰克逊显然怒不可遏。
This is going to slow him down for his meeting. His driver gets out for a moment to swap details with the driver of the red van. And Tom, that was his mistake. Because at that moment, a group of men leap out from the shadows. They jump into the car, pull open the doors. They pull out their pistols, aim them at Jeffrey Jackson. The next thing he knows, they are driving off, his driver left behind. They're herring off through the streets of Montevideo. And eventually they stop. He doesn't know where
这会耽误他开会的时间。他的司机下车片刻，去和红色面包车的司机交换信息。汤姆，这就是他的失误所在。因为就在那一刻，一群男子从阴影中跳了出来。他们冲进车里，拉开车门。他们拔出手枪，对准杰弗里·杰克逊。等他反应过来时，车子已经开走了，他的司机被留在了原地。他们风驰电掣般穿过蒙得维的亚的街道。最后他们停了下来。他不知道他们
they are. They drag him out and throw him into another van, a blue van this time. One of them rips off the sleeve of Jeffrey Jackson's suit, rolls up his shirt, jabs in a syringe as they inject him with jugs. His head is swimming, but he doesn't pass out they put they say tie a handkerchief over his eyes so he's very groggy he's half aware of where he is he's conscious that they're moving again off they go sort of um rocking over potholes and things and eventually he's conscious of them stopping and stuff going on around the van. And then the door is opened. He's still blindfolded. They drag him out.
在哪里。他们把他拖出来，扔进另一辆面包车里，这次是一辆蓝色的面包车。其中一人撕破了杰弗里·杰克逊西装的袖子，卷起他的衬衫，在注射毒品时扎入一支注射器。他头晕目眩，但并没有昏过去，他们把一条手帕系在他的眼睛上，所以他迷迷糊糊的，隐约知道自己在哪里，他感觉到他们又在移动了，出发了，在一处处水坑上颠簸着，最后他感觉到他们停了下来，面包车周围发生了一些事情。然后车门被打开了。他仍然被蒙着眼睛。他们把他拖了出来。
And then they pull off the handkerchief. And he finds himself in an underground basement. Here's Tom, a prisoner of the Tuber Maros. What was that music? That was Pampipes. That was South American Pampipes. I thought it was good to have a music... I thought it was good to have... I mean...
然后他们扯下那块手帕。他发现自己身处一个地下地下室里。汤姆，这就是图帕马罗斯游击队的囚犯。刚才那是什么音乐？那是排箫。那是南美洲的排箫。我觉得放点音乐挺好的……我觉得有……我是说……
To have a music... So that wasn't what they actually played? That's... This is... No, they didn't play any music at all. They were gorillas. They were urban gorillas. So they didn't even play...
有音乐……所以那不是他们实际播放的音乐？那是……这是……不，他们根本没有播放任何音乐。他们是游击队员。他们是城市游击队员。所以他们甚至没有播放……
Oh! No, that's how the film starts. Oh, I see. I told you it was a James Bond-style opening. Oh, I see. And then it cuts from that. Somebody says to him... That's not very James Bond.
哦！不，那是电影开场的方式。哦，我明白了。我告诉过你这是一个詹姆斯·邦德风格的开场。哦，我明白了。然后从那个画面切开。有人对他说……这可不太像詹姆斯·邦德。
I think somebody would say to him, you're a prisoner of the tuba malos. And then cue music. It would be much more Ennio Morricone. Is that what Ennio Morricone does? That's exactly what he is. It wouldn't pan pipes for a guy who's just been kidnapped. Well, anyway, listen, let's do the history behind this.
我想会有人对他说，你是图帕马罗斯的阶下囚。然后音乐响起。那会更有埃尼奥·莫里康内的风格。那是埃尼奥·莫里康内的风格吗？他就是那样的。对于一个刚刚被绑架的人来说，不该放排箫。好吧，不管怎样，听着，我们来聊聊这背后的历史吧。
I like your idea of infusing the podcast with music. I think we should do that more often. Yes, it's a brilliant idea. I'm sure no one has thought of that before. Of course they haven't. So, okay, Uruguay, you want a bit of a backstory on all this. What on earth is going on? So the subject of today's podcast is this urban guerrilla group called the Tupamanros
我喜欢你在播客中融入音乐的想法。我觉得我们应该更经常这样做。是的，这是一个绝妙的主意。我确信以前没有人想到过这一点。他们当然没有。好吧，那么，乌拉圭，你想了解这一切的背景故事。这到底是怎么回事？所以今天播客的主题是这个名为图帕马罗斯的城市游击队组织
and their impact on Uruguayan history. But first of all, as you said before we started, we really do need a sense of Uruguayan history and what's going on. So by South American standards, Uruguay is very, very small. It's nestled on the east bank of the river Uruguay, which basically flows out from the interior of Brazil all the way down to the Atlantic. And the port of Montevideo was founded by the Spanish as part of their competition with Portugal. So it's across, and it's got a kind of sister port, a rival, which is Buenos Aires.
及其对乌拉圭历史的影响。但首先，正如我们在开始之前所说，我们确实需要了解乌拉圭的历史以及正在发生的事情。按南美标准来看，乌拉圭非常非常小。它坐落在乌拉圭河的东岸，这条河基本上从巴西内流一直流向大西洋。蒙得维的亚港是西班牙人为了与葡萄牙人竞争而建立的。所以它对面，还有一个姊妹港，一个竞争对手，那就是布宜诺斯艾利斯。
So the rivalry between Buenos Aires and Montevideo is incredibly intense. So, I mean, this is a World Cup podcast, and that first World Cup final, 1930, Uray and argentina i mean it's to some sense that's a final really between montevideo and uh and river plate now why was it why does this exist at all why isn't it just part of argentina well the one reason is that um when the spanish empire collapsed at the end of the napoleonic wars the port of Montevideo was seized by Portuguese Brazil. And actually, there was a war between the Empire of Brazil and the United Provinces of Rio de la Plata, which became Argentina, for control of Montevideo. It's called the Cis-Platine War.
所以布宜诺斯艾利斯和蒙得维的亚之间的竞争极其激烈。我的意思是，这是一个世界杯播客，那场1930年的第一届世界杯决赛，乌拉圭和阿根廷，从某种意义上说，这实际上是一场蒙得维的亚与拉普塔河之间的决赛。那么为什么会这样？为什么它不只是阿根廷的一部分呢？原因之一是，拿破仑战争结束后西班牙帝国崩溃时，蒙得维的亚港被葡萄牙统治的巴西占领了。事实上，巴西帝国与里约热内卢联合省（后来成为了阿根廷）之间曾为争夺蒙得维的亚的控制权而爆发了一场战争。这被称为西斯普拉廷战争。
And it was actually the British, as always, meddling in South American affairs. They basically wanted a rival to Buenos Aires that they kind of had a controlling interest in. The British negotiator who had the splendid name Lord John Ponsonby, he wrote privately, he said, the interest and security of British commerce will be greatly promoted in a state in which the governors cultivate a friendship with England.
事实上，就像往常一样，是英国人在干涉南美事务。他们基本上想要一个布宜诺斯艾利斯的竞争对手，并且他们对这个对手拥有某种控制权。那位拥有显赫名字的英国谈判代表约翰·庞森比勋爵私下写道，他表示，在一个由其统治者培养与英国友谊的国家中，英国商业的利益和安全将得到极大的促进。
The Eastern Strip, so this is the eastern sort of bank of the river by which he means Uruguay, contains the key to La Plata and to South America. And we must perpetuate a geographical division of states that benefits England. So this is another reason why Britain is so popular with Argentina, presumably. Exactly, yes. So basically what they do is they create this or what's called the oriental republic of uruguay oriental as on the eastern side yes the eastern side it's a buffer state between brazil and portuguese brazil on the one hand and the united provinces which become argentina on the other the uruguay's history after that so effectively what you've got is one port monte video and then it's it's hinter. So it's a very small country.
东岸，也就是他所指的乌拉圭的河东岸，掌握着通往拉普塔河和南美洲的钥匙。我们必须巩固有利于英国的国家的地理划分。所以这也是为什么英国在阿根廷如此受欢迎的另一个原因，大概吧。完全正确，是的。所以基本上他们做的是创建了这个被称为乌拉圭东岸共和国的国家，东方，意为东部，是的，东部，它是巴西（一方面是葡萄牙统治的巴西）与联合省（另一方面是阿根廷）之间的缓冲区。乌拉圭之后的历史，实际上你拥有的是一个港口蒙得维的亚，然后是它的腹地。所以这是一个非常小的国家。
Its population throughout the 19th century was less than a million. It fought wars against its neighbors from time to time. It was dominated by a single party, the Colorado Party. And the big thing that transformed it was immigration. So immigration from Spain and from Italy. There's virtually no indigenous population there now whatsoever. So it's all Spanish and Italian immigrants. So in other words, it's like a little Argentina that is very conscious that it's not Argentina. The thing with Uruguay is that rather like Argentina,
在整个19世纪，它的人口不到一百万。它不时与邻国发生战争。它由单一政党红党统治。而改变它的重大事件是移民。来自西班牙和意大利的移民。现在那里几乎没有任何原住民人口。所以全都是西班牙和意大利移民。换句话说，它就像一个小阿根廷，非常清醒地意识到自己不是阿根廷。乌拉圭的情况是，和阿根廷很像，
it seemed at the beginning of the 20th century to be set fair for an absolutely splendid future. So it's this port and then farming land around it, basically. It's rich. It exports loads of wool and loads of meat. There's high price, high world prices for these things. So by the interwar years, it has paid for tons of schools and hospitals. It's got a very advanced welfare state. It has done things like it has abolished the death penalty. It has instituted women's suffrage. So when it wins the World Cup in 1930, as always in sporting history, this is actually, the sporting success is a reflection of economic success. So people often think it's a bit weird
它在20世纪初似乎注定要迎来一个绝对辉煌的未来。所以它基本上就是一个港口，周围是农田。它很富有。它出口大量的羊毛和肉类。这些商品的世界价格很高。因此，到了两次世界大战之间，它已经为数以吨计的学校和医院提供了资金。它拥有一个非常先进的福利国家。它做出了诸如废除死刑、实行妇女选举权等事情。所以当它在1930年赢得世界杯时，正如体育史上的常态一样，体育的成功实际上是经济成功的反映。所以人们通常觉得这有点奇怪
that a country as small as Uruguay wins that first world cup. It's not weird at all. It wins it because it's a very, very successful country. The highest per capita income in Latin America, very complicated social welfare system. People call it the Switzerland of the Americas. So it's a sort of haven of stability. It's a very small army, small police force. There's very little crime. Everything is great. But then after World War II, things start to go wrong, as they do across Latin America more generally. So I said that they exported wool and meat.
像乌拉圭这样小的国家竟然赢得了第一届世界杯。一点也不奇怪。它赢得比赛是因为它是一个非常非常成功的国家。拉丁美洲最高的人均收入，非常复杂的社会福利系统。人们称它为美洲的瑞士。所以它算是一个稳定的避风港。军队规模很小，警察队伍也很小。犯罪率极低。一切都好极了。但二战后，情况开始恶化，正如整个拉丁美洲更普遍的情况一样。我刚才说过他们出口羊毛和肉类。
Both of the prices for those things go into very steep decline. Uruguay is struggling to make ends meet to support its welfare system. Inflation goes through the roof. You get mass unemployment becoming a factor. to make ends meet to support its welfare system. Inflation goes through the roof, you get mass unemployment becoming a factor, the peso, the currency has to be devalued, and you start getting people writing about this intense poverty as people feel that they're missing out and that they're not getting the rewards that they expected. So it's a Uruguayan writer called Eduardo Galeano, who wrote a book that you can still see. You know, you go into a Wollaston's to the Latin American history section and they will have it.
这两种商品的价格都出现了急剧下跌。乌拉圭在收支相抵以维持其福利系统方面苦苦挣扎。通货膨胀率飙升。大规模失业成为一个因素。收支相抵以维持其福利体系变得困难，通货膨胀飙升，大规模失业成为现实，比索（货币）不得不贬值，人们开始撰写关于这种极度贫困的文章，因为人们觉得他们被抛弃了，没有得到他们期望的回报。所以有一位乌拉圭作家叫爱德华多·加莱亚诺，他写了一本你至今还能见到的书。你知道的，你走进一家书店的拉丁美洲历史专区就能找到它。
It's called The Open Veins of Latin America. It's seen as a classic of Latin American political historical writing. And Galeano, it's a sort of left wing account of how Latin America has been betrayed by world capitalism. And he wrote in 1971, this gives you a sense of the sort of very fevered tone of the conversation. The human murder by poverty in Latin America is a secret. Every year, without making a sound, three Hiroshima bombs explode over communities that have become accustomed to suffering with clenched teeth. And what Galeano was writing reflected what a lot of young Uruguayans thought.
这本书叫《拉丁美洲被切开的血管》。它被视为拉丁美洲政治历史写作的经典之作。加莱亚诺用一种左翼视角描述了拉丁美洲是如何被世界资本主义背叛的。他在1971年写道，这让你对当时那种狂热的谈话语调有所体会。拉丁美洲因贫困而遭受的人类谋杀是一个秘密。每年，三颗广岛原子弹在那些已经习惯了咬紧牙关忍受痛苦的社群上空悄无声息地爆炸。而加莱亚诺所写的，正是许多年轻的乌拉圭人所想的。
They thought that basically their dream had been taken away from them and that they were condemned to life with kind of inflation and unemployment and all of these kinds of things. Thank God that doesn't happen here. Exactly. And there's no, yes, exactly. Well, will we get a Tupper Maros of our own? I don't know.
他们认为，基本上他们的梦想被剥夺了，他们注定要过上伴随着通货膨胀、失业以及所有这些事情的生活。谢天谢地，这种事在这里不会发生。完全正确。而且没有，是的，完全正确。好吧，我们也会迎来我们自己的图帕马罗斯游击队吗？我不知道。
So one of these people who thinks this is a guy called Raoul Sendik. So his father was a peasant outside Montevideo. He's that classic example, which you see time and time again in kind of extremist groups or terrorist groups, of somebody who was the bright boy from a poor family who's gone away to university and sort of, you know, he's educated himself. He's filled his head with stuff. But there's a lot of anger and resentment there when that society doesn't really seem to have a niche for him. So like Prince Harry. Yes, exactly.
持有这种想法的人之一是一个叫劳尔·森迪克的人。他的父亲是蒙得维的亚郊区的一个农民。他是那种在极端主义组织或恐怖组织中屡见不鲜的典型例子：一个来自贫困家庭的聪慧男孩，去上大学并自我教育。他的脑子里装满了各种东西。但当这个社会似乎并没有为他提供一席之地时，心中便充满了愤怒和怨恨。就像哈里王子一样。是的，完全一样。
Just like Prince Harry. Prince Harry did not go to university, though, Tom. That's true. Yes, that's true. I think Raoul Sendik was a more, how should I put this? I think he was a more academically accomplished man than Prince Harry. I think he was more academically accomplished than Prince Harry. So Raoul Sendik, he went to university in Montevideo. He did a law degree. He joins the Socialist Party. He was very active in kind of young socialist politics.
就像哈里王子一样。不过汤姆，哈里王子可没上过大学。确实如此。是的，没错。我想劳尔·森迪克是一个更……我该怎么说呢？我认为他在学术上比哈里王子更有成就。我认为他在学术上比哈里王子更有成就。所以劳尔·森迪克去蒙得维的亚上了大学。他获得了法律学位。他加入了社会党。他在青年社会主义政治中非常活跃。
He's horrified by what he sees as the mistreatment of agricultural laborers outside the city. He starts a campaign to get better working conditions and things for cane workers and they might that he organizes a protest in montevideo which is very violently repressed and that sort of pushes him um further and further to the left and so in 1963 so we're just up we're not that long after the cuban revolution yeah a lot of very bright people in these places are influenced by what's happening cuba he sets up a group called the Movimiento de Liberación Nacional, but it's better known by its nickname, the Tupamanos.
他对城外农业劳工所遭受的虐待感到震惊。他发起了一场运动，为甘蔗工人争取更好的工作条件等等，他组织了一场在蒙得维的亚的抗议活动，遭到了极其暴力的镇压，这某种程度上把他一步步推向了更左的道路。所以在1963年——也就是古巴革命后不久——是的，这些地方许多才华横溢的人都受到了古巴发生的事情的影响，他建立了一个名为“民族解放运动”的组织，但人们更习惯用它的绰号“图帕马罗斯”来称呼它。
So it's named specifically after the last great kind of Peruvian Inca rebel, who was a guy called Tupac Amaru II, who lived and died in Peru in the 1700s, so 1740 to about 17, to 1781. So he was the, he himself, Tupac Amaru II, was a descendant of the last ruling Inca, Tupac Amaru I. So this is all very Tintin. Yeah, absolutely. Tintin and the Picaros. Is that kind of thing? Yes. So presumably that's where Hergé is drawing on. I think there's a huge, exactly. I think there's a huge... Exactly.
所以它直接以最后一位伟大的秘鲁印加起义领袖的名字命名，那个人叫图帕库·阿马鲁二世，他生活并死于18世纪的秘鲁，大约从1740年活到1781年左右。所以他本人，图帕库·阿马鲁二世，是最后一位统治印加人图帕库·阿马鲁一世的后代。所以这一切都非常像《丁丁历险记》。是的，绝对是的。《丁丁与皮卡罗斯》。是那种风格吗？是的。所以这大概就是埃尔热的灵感来源吧。我认为这里面有很大一部分，完全正确。我认为有很大一部分……完全正确。
I think there's a huge element of Tintin and the Picard Ross about this. So Tupac Amaru II had rebelled against the Spanish in the 1770s. He had been captured. He was taken to Cuzco. What happened to him was horrific. He was forced to witness the execution of his wife and his sons, and then he himself was hanged, drawn, and quartered, and then beheaded. So very grim end for Tubac Amri II.
我认为这里面有很大一部分《丁丁与皮卡罗斯》的影子。图帕库·阿马鲁二世在18世纪70年代曾反抗西班牙人。他被俘虏了。他被带到了库斯科。他的遭遇极其可怕。他被迫目睹了自己的妻子和儿子被处决，然后他自己也被施以绞刑、车裂并斩首。所以图帕库·阿马鲁二世的结局非常凄惨。
But before he died, he said in Quechua. How's your Quechua, Tom? I thought it was Quecha. Is it? Well, there you go. It's better than mine. That's clearly better than mine. So you'll be able to please judge my pronunciation.
但在他死前，他用克丘亚语说道。汤姆，你的克丘亚语怎么样？我以为那是克丘亚语。是吗？好吧，你看。它比我的好。这显然比我的好。所以你一定能评判我的发音。
He said, That's clearly more best than fine. So you'll be able to, please, judge my pronunciation. He said, Tikrashami hunu makana koipikasha. And obviously you all know what that means. Yes, but probably for the benefit of those who don't, you should say what it actually means. He said, I'll be back and there'll be millions of us. Hasta la vista.
他说，这明显比好的还要好。所以你一定能评判我的发音。他说：Tikrashami hunu makana koipikasha。显然你们都知道这是什么意思。是的，不过为了那些不知道的人，你大概应该解释一下它实际上是什么意思。他说：我会回来的，而且我们会有千百万人。再见。
Yeah, he said, I'll be back and there will be millions of us. And since then, Tupac Amaru II's words had resounded down the generations. For people who basically dreamed of an alternative to what, I suppose, what they saw as conservatism, capitalism, Hispanicization. But I thought you said that everyone there weren't that everyone there was spanish and that's the that's the glorious irony that um ryle sendic i'm assuming from his from his surname that his surname was probably originally sendich and he was perhaps balkan that there was some yeah balkan immigrants in his background but the people of uruguay are of spanish and italian
是的，他说，我会回来的，我们将有数百万之众。自那以后，图帕库·阿马鲁二世的话语在数代人中回响。对于那些梦想着找到一种替代方案的人来说，我猜，他们所认为的保守主义、资本主义、西班牙化。但你不是说那里每个人都是西班牙人，而且——这就是光荣的讽刺之处，劳尔·森迪克——从他的姓氏来看，我猜他的姓氏最初可能是森迪奇，他可能是巴尔干人，他的背景中可能有一些巴尔干移民，但乌拉圭人民具有西班牙和意大利
extraction but there's this kind of romanticization isn't there of the indigenous But the people of Uruguay are of Spanish and Italian extraction. But there's this kind of romanticization, isn't there, of the indigenous. And you see this in Latin America. You see it every, I mean, you see it in lots of places, but not least in Latin America. This romanticization of the sort of indigenous resistance, which becomes melded. Despite the fact that he was a king. This is a Marxist group, but they're identifying. So there's lots of weirdness going on then.
血统，但对原住民有一种浪漫化的情怀，不是吗？但乌拉圭人民拥有西班牙和意大利血统。然而，对原住民有一种浪漫化的倾向，不是吗？你在拉丁美洲能看到这一点。你在各个地方都能看到，我的意思是，你在很多地方都能看到，尤其是在拉丁美洲。这种对原住民抵抗运动的浪漫化与……融为一体。尽管他是一个国王。这是一个马克思主义组织，但他们认同……所以这里面有很多奇特之处。
Yeah. They're Spanish, but they're identifying with the indigenous people of a totally different country but this was very yeah but this was very much the trend and they're communists they're marxist but they're identifying with a king yeah yeah okay the downtrodden masses yeah a representative of the downtrodden masses tom yeah um so they set up this uh this urban guerrilla group. Cellular structure, the classic thing that you get among urban guerrillas. They start off from 1963. They basically start off as bank robbers because they need to make money. They have no resources.
是的。他们是西班牙人，但他们认同完全不同国家的原住民，但这也确实是当时的潮流，他们是共产主义者，他们是马克思主义者，但他们认同国王。是的，是的，好吧。受压迫的群众，是的，受压迫群众的代表，汤姆。是的，所以他们建立了这个城市游击队组织。细胞结构，你在城市游击队中能看到的经典模式。他们从1963年开始。他们基本上从银行抢劫犯做起，因为他们需要赚钱。他们没有任何资源。
They have all kinds of heists. They get a sort of slightly Robin Hood reputation. So they rob a casino in the resort of Punta del Este, and there they steal all the money, and then they send back tips for the people working at the casino. So they do all these kinds of things. The government tries to crack down and fails, gets the United States to help. So the United States says,
他们进行了各种各样的抢劫。他们获得了一种略带罗宾汉色彩的声誉。例如，他们抢劫了蓬塔德尔埃斯特度假胜地的赌场，偷走了所有的钱，然后给赌场的工作人员寄回了小费。所以他们做了所有这些事情。政府试图镇压却失败了，于是寻求美国的帮助。美国人说，
we will send people to train your police in counterinsurgency and so on. This will become important. This will become important later on. And so this is this is um americans training latin american countries police forces in the 70s and stuff it's generally not yeah well we'll come to this because this is a really really important point should we take a break at this point uh if you're like if you want to if you're if you want to go and listen to some
我们将派人来训练你们的警察进行反叛乱等等。这将会很重要。这在以后会变得很重要。所以这是……美国人在70年代训练拉丁美洲国家的警察部队等等，这通常不是……是的，我们会谈到这一点，因为这是一个非常非常重要的点。我们现在要不要休息一下？如果你想的话……如果你想去听一些
more pan pipes is that what it is well do you want to play us out with some panpipes? Do you have some to hand? It's sort of the same. Well, let's have it again. I'm sure that people enjoyed it the first time. So goodbye. We'll be back very soon. We'll leave you for a moment with the Tupper Maros theme. Take us out. I'm Marina Hyde.
更多的排箫声，是这样吗？好吧，你想用一些排箫音乐来结束这段吗？你手头有吗？这差不多是一样的。好吧，让我们再听一遍。我确信大家第一次听时都很享受。所以再见。我们将离开片刻，留下图帕马罗斯的主题音乐。带我们结束吧。我是玛丽娜·海德。
And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History. i think that everyone will agree uh after the end
我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一丝娱乐圈八卦的地方，在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚成立了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家加更节目和抢先购买现场门票的机会，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《历史的余烬》。我想大家都会同意，在前半场结束之后
of the first half that this whole idea of integrating music stop it dominic of integrating music into history podcasts is a ludicrous idea and it will never work so um so dominic please no more pan pipes um but we're talking about the two pomaros yes i've never heard of before but i now know lots about but i want to know what happens dominic so could you could you tell me and could you tell the listeners i will do i will do it and maybe you know what tom we could i mean maybe we could sneak a bit of music back in later okay well if i tell you what if if you do a good job i will let you do that yes brilliant but you've got to do a good job so 1968 the uruguayan government declared a state of emergency they were completely failing to deal with these the two pomeros uh the
，将音乐融入历史播客的整个想法——住嘴，多米尼克——将音乐融入历史播客的想法简直荒谬至极，而且永远行不通。所以……所以多米尼克，请不要再放排箫了。不过我们在谈论图帕马罗斯。是的，我以前从未听说过，但我现在了解了很多，但我想知道接下来发生了什么，多米尼克。所以你能告诉我，也能告诉听众们吗？我会的，我会的。也许你知道吗，汤姆，我们可以在稍后偷偷加回一点音乐。好吧，如果我告诉你，如果你表现得好，我会让你那样做的。太棒了。但你得表现好才行。所以在1968年，乌拉圭政府宣布进入紧急状态，他们完全无法应对图帕马罗斯游击队。
two pomeros up their game and are they growing at this point yeah it's still just a kind of barnabine hoff small there i think they're larger than barter than a barnabine hoff kind of red brigade that kind of level a bit like italy maybe yes exactly i would say a little bit like that they have one they have a couple of tactics that I don't think we should adopt on the rest of this history, and one they do. So the ones that I don't recommend are the intimidation of the police by selective assassinations of policemen. We're not really in favour of that, I think.
图帕马罗斯游击队加大了他们的力度，他们在这个时候在壮大吗？是的，它仍然只是一个类似于巴纳比·霍夫的小规模组织。我觉得他们比巴纳比·霍夫那种红旅规模要大一点，大概是意大利那种水平，也许吧？是的，完全正确，我想有点类似于那样。他们有一些战术，我觉得我们不应该在《历史的余烬》中采用，但有一种他们用了。我不推荐的战术是通过选择性暗杀警察来恐吓警察。我们其实并不赞成那样，我认为。
No, we're not. The other is kidnapping. We'll come back to kidnapping because, of course, we started with the kidnapping of the British ambassador. So you're categorically ruling that out? I'm ruling that out. But the one thing I would like to see us doing, Tom, is a bit more armed propaganda.
不，我们不赞成。另一种是绑架。我们会回到绑架这个话题上，因为我们一开始就从绑架英国大使说起了。所以你彻底排除了那种可能性？我排除了那种可能性。但我希望看到我们做的一件事，汤姆，是进行更多的武装宣传。
Okay. So what that means is that they would basically invade, groups of them with weapons would unexpectedly invade places where people were meeting. So they'd invade restaurants or cinemas or theatres. And they would make, it says in the thing I read, they would make speeches to a literally captive audience. Yeah, well, that's a way of promoting the Restless History Club.
好的。这意味着他们基本上会侵入，成群结队携带武器的人会出其不意地闯入人们聚集的地方。所以他们会侵入餐厅、电影院或剧院。正如我读到的资料所说，他们会对实际上被软禁的观众发表演讲。是的，这也是推广《历史的余烬》俱乐部的一种方式。
Absolutely, exactly. If not enough people join the Restless History Club, we will be forced to take extreme measures, burst into cinemas or whatever, and do podcast force people to listen to our podcasts yeah at machine gun point kidnapping became their sort of signature tactic so for example they kidnapped the head of the state telephone company in the summer of 1968 and then in 1969 they kidnapped one of the Uruguay's leading bankers. And what did they do to them?
绝对的，完全正确。如果没有足够多的人加入《历史的余烬》俱乐部，我们将被迫采取极端措施，闯入电影院什么的，做播客强迫人们听我们的播客，拿机枪指着他们。绑架成了他们的标志性战术。例如，他们在1968年夏天绑架了国家电话公司的负责人，然后在1969年绑架了乌拉圭的一位主要银行家。他们对这些人做了什么？
They usually hold them for sort of 10 weeks or so in support of a strike or something or demanding a ransom. And then release them? Or do they chop ears off? By and large, they're not unnecessarily cruel. Right. I mean, these are people who began as... But are they saying, give the workers better rights?
他们通常把他们扣押大约10周左右，以支持某次罢工或提出某种勒索要求。然后释放他们？还是割掉他们的耳朵？总的来说，他们并不是不必要的残酷。对。我的意思是，这些人最初是……但他们是在说“给工人更多权利”吗？
Or are they saying, give us $200,000? I mean, what was... No, it's a bit of both. It's a little bit of both. So, for example, when they kidnapped the guy who was the banker in September 1969, they held him for 10 weeks, but that was in support of a strike by employees at his bank. Right. So they said better terms for the...
还是在说“给我们20万美元”？我的意思是，那是什么……不，两者兼而有之。两者都有一点。例如，当他们在1969年9月绑架那名银行家时，他们扣押了他10周，但这支架是为了支持他银行雇员的罢工。对。所以他们要求为……
And did it work? I think it did work. Yeah, I think it did work. Okay. The government is completely unable to deal with this. The government is calling up, starts to call up more and more kind of paramilitaries. So what's happening is actually the Uruguayan government, which is previously more democratic, is moving towards more and more authoritarian measures.
这起作用了吗？我想确实起作用了。是的，我想确实起作用了。好吧。政府完全无力应对这一局面。政府开始征召越来越多的准军事人员。所以实际发生的情况是，此前更加民主的乌拉圭政府正朝着越来越专制的措施发展。
So you've got this ratchet. Yeah. The more that the Tuber Maros sort of carry out their sort of spectacular coups, the more the government becomes the government that they think it is if you know what i mean they think it's fascistic and all this sort of stuff so as i said we began that thrilling scene at the beginning of the podcast in january 1971 when jeffrey jackson was imprisoned so he was kept in prison tom for 244 days goodness that is a long time that is a very long time.
所以你看到了这种恶性循环。是的。图帕马罗斯游击队实施的壮观行动越多，政府就越变成他们所认为的那种政府，如果你明白我的意思的话。他们认为它是法西斯主义的等等。正如我所说，我们在播客开头讲了那个惊心动魄的场景：1971年1月，杰弗里·杰克逊被监禁。所以他被关在监狱里，汤姆，长达244天。天哪，那可真是一段很长的时间。那确实是一段非常长的时间。
So it was quite a big story in Britain at the time. Utterly forgotten now, but it was quite a big story. They released one photograph of him, his kidnappers, showing him having grown this colossal... He wasn't allowed to shave, so he looked like Moses. He'd grown this huge, flowing white beard. The Uruguayan government were completely embarrassed by this. They sent people out all across Montevideo searching for him never found all through the during the time he was a
所以在当时的英国，这是一件相当大的新闻。现在完全被遗忘了，但当时是个大新闻。他们发布了他的一张照片，他的绑架者拍的，显示他留着极其浓密的胡须。他不被允许刮胡子，所以他看起来像摩西一样。他留着巨大的、飘逸的白色胡须。乌拉圭政府对此感到十分尴尬。他们派人在蒙得维的亚到处搜寻他，却从未找到。在他是阶下囚的期间，他的绑架者一直戴着面具。他们想要什么？
prisoner his captors wore masks and what did they want well they basically wanted um the very this is a very confusing thing they never issued any ransom demand at all they basically just issued a letter saying the british of the British piratical leeches have stolen all Uruguay's wealth, representatives of capitalism, imperialism, and so on. But they didn't really issue any very concrete demands, so it's quite hard to deal with them. They told Jackson, they said,
他们基本上想要……这是一个非常混乱的问题，他们从未发出任何赎金要求。他们基本上只发表了一封信，称英国的英国海盗式水蛭偷走了乌拉圭的所有财富，他们是资本主义、帝国主义等的代表。但他们并没有真正提出任何非常具体的诉求，所以很难与他们打交道。他们对杰克逊说：
if the security forces ever find where we've got you, we will kill you on the spot. So that was bad news from his perspective because it means, you know, does he hope for escape or not? They did arrange an interview for him with a Cuban journalist in which he talks to this Cuban and he sort of says, well, I jog around my cells, keep fit and all this kind of thing and I'm in decent health. But he wasn't actually released until the 9th of September
如果安全部队找到我们关押你的地方，我们会就地处决你。从他的角度来看，这不是什么好消息，因为这意味着，他到底该不该希望有人来营救他呢？他们确实为他安排了一次与古巴记者的采访，在采访中他与这位古巴人交谈，他说，我在牢房里慢跑以保持身材之类的，我的健康状况还算不错。但直到1971年
1971 they had been demanding the release of some of their their fellow prisoners so they'd finally issued a proper demand but that presumably is the responsibility of the Uruguayan government so it's not it's nothing the British have done no nothing the British can do about it they basically wanted the British they wanted the Uruguayan government to release all these prisoners, 106 prisoners in a jail in Montevideo. Eventually the prisoners just escaped anyway. Okay.
年9月9日他才真正获释。他们曾要求释放他们的一些同伙囚犯，所以他们终于提出了一个正式的要求，但那大概是乌拉圭政府的责任，所以这与英国人做的事无关，英国人对此也无能为力。他们基本上希望英国人——希望乌拉圭政府释放所有这些囚犯，蒙得维的亚监狱里的106名囚犯。最终这些囚犯无论如何都逃跑了。好吧。
Or do you think they were sprung by MI6? Well, not by MI6. I mean, it might have been some collusion with the Uruguayan government. So Geoffrey Jackson had been in prison for eight months. He was left out, he was blindfolded, and he was taken and left outside the church. And then he flew back to Britain.
或者你认为他们是被军情六处（MI6）劫狱救出来的？嗯，不是军情六处。我的意思是，可能与乌拉圭政府有某种勾结。所以杰弗里·杰克逊被关押了八个月。他被释放了，被蒙上双眼，然后被带到并扔在了一座教堂外面。接着他飞回了英国。
Ted Heath gave him a knighthood. Oh, so it wasn't all bad. No, for services to being a hostage. So that was nice for him. But of course, the one reason perhaps we don't remember it is it was eclipsed by what is by far the Tupper Maris' most famous kidnapping. And this was of a man, I mean, I say famous,
特德·希思授予了他爵士称号。哦，所以还不算太糟。是的，为了表彰他作为人质做出的贡献。所以这对他是件好事。但当然，我们可能不记得这件事的一个原因，是它被图帕马罗斯游击队最著名的一次绑架事件给掩盖了。这是一个人的事——我的意思是，我说著名，
a lot of people won't have heard of this, although it was later made into a film. This was a man called Dan Mitrioni, and this happened in 1970. So Dan Mitrioni, Tom, you were talking about Americans training Latin American policemen and so on. Yeah. Dan Mitrioni is an American policeman. He'd been the police chief in richmond
很多人可能都没听说过，尽管后来被拍成了电影。这个人叫丹·米蒂奥尼（Dan Mitrioni），这发生在1970年。所以丹·米蒂奥尼，汤姆，你刚才提到美国人训练拉丁美洲警察等等。是的。丹·米蒂奥尼是一名美国警察。他曾是印第安纳州里士满的警察局长，
indiana and in the 50s and 60s and then he joined a program called the international cooperation administration which sounds like nothing sounds very sinister exactly it was it provided us training to civilian policemen so his first posting posting was to Belo Horizonte in Brazil, and then he's transferred to Rio. And it's later been claimed that when he was in Rio, he helped to train the Brazilian police and has tortured their own people. And then he goes to Uruguay. Now, what Mitrioni was doing in Uruguay remains the source of great controversy.
在50世纪和60年代，然后他加入了一个名为国际合作署的项目，听起来什么也不像，听起来非常阴险，确实如此，它为平民警察提供美国式的训练，所以他的第一个岗位是巴西贝洛奥里藏特，随后他被调往里约热内卢。后来有人声称，他在里约热内卢时，曾协助训练巴西警察并折磨他们自己的人民。然后他去了乌拉圭。现在，米蒂奥尼在乌拉圭的所作所为仍然充满巨大争议。
And it's a very good example of how sometimes in history, I think you just have to admit, we don't know and we will never know. The truth is unattainable. But presumably people are prone to favouring their opinion of what was happening, reflects their political assumptions, I would guess. Totally, totally and utterly. So some former Uruguayan policemen and people who worked with the CIA in Uruguay said, they said Mitrioni was the head of torture.
这是一个很好的例子，说明有时在历史中，我认为你只能承认，我们不知道，也永远不会知道。真相是无法企及的。但人们大概倾向于支持符合他们政治假设的对当时发生事情的看法，我猜。完全、彻底地如此。因此，一些前乌拉圭警察和在乌拉圭与中情局合作过的人说，他们说米蒂奥尼是酷刑的负责人。
So Mitrioni taught you how to, literally taught you how to electrocute people's genitals. And his credo, his guiding principle was the precise pain in the precise place in the precise amount for the desired effect, which is quite sinister. A Cuban guy claimed that he had infiltrated the CIA as a double agent. He said Mitrioni would abduct homeless people from the streets of Montevideo, and he would use them as guinea pigs in his torture classes. He said Mitrioni would keep the victims alive for multiple torture sessions, but eventually they'd die, and then Mitrioni would dump their bodies in the streets. So that's kind of very sinister. On the other hand, some people who worked with Mitrioni in the CIA say this is absolute nonsense,
所以米蒂奥尼教你如何……字面意思是教你如何电击人们的生殖器。他的信条、他的指导原则是：在精确的地点以精确的数量施加精确的痛苦，以达到预期的效果，这相当阴险。一名古巴人声称他作为双重间谍渗透进了中情局。他说米蒂奥尼会从蒙得维的亚的街头绑架无家可归的人，并将他们作为自己酷刑课上的小白鼠。他说米蒂奥尼会让受害者在多次酷刑审讯中活下来，但最终他们会死去，然后米蒂奥尼会把他们的尸体扔在街上。所以这听起来非常阴险。另一方面，一些曾在中情局与米蒂奥尼合作过的人说这纯属无稽之谈，
he didn't do this at all. He was advising in kind of, you know, counterinsurgency and riot control and these kinds of things, but torture was completely not part of his remit and he would never have dreamed of this. And how reliable are they? Well, this is the thing, Tom. How can you possibly know? You could say, well, they would say that, wouldn't they? I think I would say that. They would say that if they were covering up for him, but equally, Tom would say that if he was it was innocent and they were just his mates but they don't but but by and large people don't fix on one person and say he was the chief torturer i mean there must have been lots of lots of americans kind of playing a role in in a similar
他根本没做过这种事。他是在反叛乱、防暴控制等方面提供建议，但酷刑绝对不属于他的职责范围，他做梦也不会想到这一点。他们有多大程度的可信度？这就是问题所在，汤姆。你怎么可能知道？你会说，嗯，他们当然会那么说。我想我也会这么说。如果他们是在为他掩盖真相，他们会这么说；但同样地，如果他是无辜的，而他们只是他的朋友，汤姆也会这么说。但他们不会……不过总的来说，人们不会锁定一个人并说他是首席拷问者——我的意思是，肯定有很多人扮演了类似的
role right but the reason we're having a conversation about him is because he was kidnapped. Here's the twist. Raoul Sendik later was asked, why did you kidnap Mitrioni? This is 1987. And he said, because he trained the police in riot control and because the policemen had killed some student protesters while suppressing riots. But he didn't mention torture or electrodes or anything.
角色，对吧？但我们讨论他的原因是因为他被绑架了。这里有个转折。后来有人问劳尔·森迪克：你为什么要绑架米蒂奥尼？那是1987年。他说，因为他训练警察进行防暴控制，而且警察在镇压暴乱时杀害了一些学生抗议者。但他没有提到酷刑、电极或任何类似的东西。
They're the head of the Tupper Maros. So why didn't he mention it if the torture was the main issue? So in other words, it's a very confused story. And listeners will probably have already jumped to their own conclusions based on their own politics, which is what we all do. I think the only honest answer we can say is that we just don't know whether he did all this we do know though what happened to him he was kidnapped on the 31st of of july but then within a week the uruguayan police captured a lot of the tupermaros leadership so that meant that mityonis captors the guards were left without instructions about what to do with him so he's still in some basement somewhere they demand the release of political prisoners. And they say, if you don't release them, 150 political prisoners, we will
他们是图帕马罗斯的领导层。所以如果酷刑是主要问题，他为什么不提呢？换句话说，这是一个非常混乱的故事。听众们可能已经根据自己的政治立场得出了自己的结论，这也是我们所有人都会做的。我认为我们唯一能给出的诚实答案是，我们根本不知道他是否做了所有这些事。不过我们确实知道他遭遇了什么：他在7月31日被绑架，但在一个星期内，乌拉圭警察抓获了许多图帕马罗斯的领导层。这意味着米蒂奥尼的绑架者、看守们失去了关于如何处置他的指示。所以他仍然被关在某个地下室里，他们要求释放政治犯。他们说，如果你不释放他们，那150名政治犯，我们将
kill Mitrioni. And the Uruguayan government says, well, we're not going to release them. And so a few days later, Mitrioni is found dead in a car, having been shot twice in the head. And the reason this is well known, became briefly well known is because it was made into a film by costa gavris the guy who made zed if you've ever seen the film zed or uh missing with jack lemon and sissy spacek so he made very political kind of hollywood thrillers in the 60s 70s and 80s and mitrioni in the film is played by Yves Montand, a great French actor. In a funny twist, the film was all about the Mitrioni kidnapping, but it was filmed in Chile under Salvador Allende. So in that brief window of time before Salvador Allende himself
米特里奥内被杀。乌拉圭政府说，好吧，我们不打算释放他们。几天后，米特里奥内被发现死在一辆车里，头部中了两枪。这件事之所以广为人知，曾短暂名声大噪，是因为它被科斯塔-加夫拉斯拍成了电影。就是拍过《Z》的那个人，如果你看过电影《Z》，或者杰克·莱蒙和茜茜·斯派塞克的《失踪》的话，就会知道他。他在60、70和80年代拍摄了非常具有政治色彩的好莱坞惊悚片。电影中的米特里奥内由法国伟大演员伊夫·蒙坦饰演。有趣的是，这部电影讲述的是绑架米特里奥内事件，但却是在萨尔瓦多·阿连德统治下的智利拍摄的。因此，在萨尔瓦多·阿连德本人
was toppled by the Pinochet queue. Why did they cast a Frenchman to play an American? Yves Montand had already played the protagonist in Costa Gavras' film Zed, which is about the Greek colonels and about repression in Greece. So Costa Gavras, he's a very great filmmaker, and his film State of Siege is incredibly atmospheric. It's very pan-pipey, Tom. It's sort of, everything is very misty and gloomy in Montevideo.
被皮诺切特政变推翻前的短暂窗口期里，他们为什么要找一个法国人来扮演美国人？伊夫·蒙坦曾在科斯塔-加夫拉斯的电影《Z》中扮演主角，该片讲述的是希腊军官和希腊镇压事件。所以科斯塔-加夫拉斯是一位非常伟大的电影制作人，他的电影《围戒》极具氛围感。汤姆，里面有很多排箫的声音。蒙得维的亚的一切都雾蒙蒙、阴沉沉的。
It's always kind of raining. And so pro? The Tupper Maros. Yeah, in a way, although, I mean, it's one of those films from the 70s where there were just... Everyone's terrible. Everyone's terrible. And there were just colossal stretches of people
总是下着雨。所以，支持图帕马罗斯游击队？是的，某种程度上，虽然，我的意思是，那是70年代的那些电影之一，里面每个人都很糟糕。每个人都很糟糕。里面有大量冗长的镜头，讲的是人们
having political conversations in basements, wearing hoods, talking about the means of production or something. But it's oddly watchable. Anyway, in the aftermath of the Mitrioni kidnapping, the Jeffrey Jackson kidnapping, the Uruguayan president basically announced a massive crackdown. He said, we're in a state of war. I mean, hence the title of the Costa Gavras film, State of Siege. There's mass arrests, there's all kinds of tortures. Basically, the government wins, but it crushes the Tupper Maros, but at the price of destroying Uruguayan democracy. So to give you a sense of that, the army in Uruguay before this crisis had accounted for about 1% of Uruguay's national budget. By the time it's over, it accounts for almost 30%. And presumably a lot of that is being spent on reflective sunglasses and
在地下室里进行政治对话，戴着头套，谈论生产资料之类的事情。但它却出奇地好看。无论如何，在米特里奥内绑架案和杰弗里·杰克逊绑架案发生之后，乌拉圭总统基本上宣布进行大规模镇压。他说，我们处于战争状态。这就是科斯塔-加夫拉斯的电影《围戒》片名的由来。这里有大规模逮捕，有各种各样的酷刑。基本上，政府赢了，粉碎了图帕马罗斯游击队，但代价是摧毁了乌拉圭的民主。为了让你对这一点有个概念，在这次危机之前，乌拉圭军队约占乌拉圭国家预算的1%。等到结束时，这一比例已近30%。想必其中很大一部分都花在了反光太阳镜和
cattle prods. Exactly. Yeah, a lot of braid absolutely it is so in other words it's become a very very repressive garrison kind of state trade unionism for example is outlawed all trade unions are outlawed 5 000 people are thrown into prison what a sad story what a sad story so one in five uruguayans was arrested one in in five? Yeah, at some stage during the dictatorship. So basically democracy suspended between 1973 and 1985 in this sort of Switzerland of South America.
电击棒上。没错。是的，有很多肩章，绝对是的。换句话说，它变成了一个非常非常压抑的类似卫戍部队的国家。例如，工会主义被取缔，所有工会都被取缔，5000人被投入监狱。多么悲惨的故事，多么悲惨的故事。因此，五分之一的乌拉圭人被捕。五分之一？是的，在独裁统治期间的某个阶段。基本上，在南美的这个“瑞士”，1973年至1985年期间民主暂停了。
And during this period, Uruguay has the highest number proportionate political prisoners in the world, more than anywhere else. So it's like Argentina, it's a kind of terrible warning that a prosperous advanced welfare state yeah tom i can see where you're going with this i don't know i'm not i'm not i'm just leaving it hanging there but but but argentina is always the example that
在此期间，乌拉圭拥有世界上最高比例的政治犯，比其他任何地方都多。所以这就像阿根廷一样，这是一个可怕的警告，一个繁荣先进的福利国家——是的，汤姆，我能看出你想说什么，我不知道，我不是，我不是，我只是把它放在那里，但是阿根廷一直是那个
is cited but uruguay as well but it's arguably you you might say even more extreme now i think that was a bit bleak, so I think we should have a slightly happy ending. I mean, we'll get there through some... The medium of music. No, no. We'll get there through the medium of even greater torture and horror. But we'll get to the happy ending, I promise.
被引用的例子，乌拉圭也是，但可以说，你甚至可以说它更极端。现在，我觉得刚才有点凄凉，所以我觉得我们应该有一个稍微圆满的结局。我的意思是，我们会通过一些……音乐媒介来实现。不，不。我们会通过更加残酷的虐待和恐怖来实现。但我保证，我们会迎来一个圆满的结局。
So the two Primaris leadership were almost all arrested. Some of them fled the country, but by and large, they were all arrested and thrown into prison where they were treated abysmally. Raoul Sendik, he was in prison. He ended up later on going to Paris, and he died in Paris in 1989. But the more famous example, certainly, I mean, I don't believe we do have any Uruguayan listeners, but if we do, they will know where I'm going with this, was a man called Jose Muica. So Muica, he's Uruguay in one person. His parents are kind of immigrants from the Basque country and from Italy, from Liguria. He had joined the Tupomeras
图帕马罗斯的领导层几乎全部被捕。他们中的一些人逃离了国家，但大体上，他们都被捕并被投入监狱，在那里受到了极其恶劣的对待。劳尔·森迪克被关在监狱里。他后来去了巴黎，于1989年在巴黎去世。但更著名的例子是——当然，我不认为我们有什么乌拉圭听众，但如果有的话，他们会知道我在说什么——是一个名叫何塞·穆希卡的人。所以穆希卡，他一个人就代表了乌拉圭。他的父母是来自巴斯克地区和意大利利古里亚的移民。他加入了图帕马罗斯
in the mid-60s. He had led some of the sort of robberies and stuff. He had been shot in 1970 by the police and was and only just lived he was taken to hospital the surgeon sort of managed to just about sew him back together um his insides and afterwards muhika thought that the surgeon had saved him because the surgeon was a jupiter sympathizer actually the surgeon said later he did it just because it was his medical job duty yeah exactly hypocritical but exactly but he is then captured in 1972 muiga and the um the hunter the people who run uruguay they keep him at the bottom i mean this will give you a sense of the conditions they keep him at the bottom of a horse watering trough he's basically trapped in this horse trough for two years two years yeah in a horse trough which is which is pretty awful um he is he's he's because he's been injured by bullets and he's got this problem with his guts he's in
在65年代中期。他领导了一些抢劫之类的活动。他在1970年被警察枪击，勉强活了下来。他被送到医院，外科医生勉强把他的内脏缝合在了一起。后来，穆希卡认为外科医生救他是因为外科医生是图帕马罗斯的同情者。实际上，外科医生后来表示，他这么做只是因为那是他的医疗职责。是的，完全是虚伪的，但确实如此。但他随后在1972年被捕，穆希卡和军政府，那些统治乌拉圭的人，把他关在——这能让你体会到当时的条件——关在马饮水槽的底部。他基本上被困在这个马槽里两年。两年？是的，在一个马槽里，这挺糟糕的。他因为被子弹打伤，肠子有问题，在这段时间里承受了
terrible pain for a lot of this time he's driven kind of half mad he's not allowed any form of toilet like a lot of the prisoners weren't they They were allowed family visits from time to time. His mother brought him a potty. She bought a potty from a shop and took it because he said it's the one thing he wanted that would make his life more bearable. But the guards wouldn't give it to him. They only relented and gave it to him after one day the jailers had a party. And Mujica made such a fuss, screaming and shouting and sobbing and shouting for his party that they finally brought it to him.
极大的痛苦。他几乎被折磨得半疯，像许多囚犯一样，他不被允许上厕所。他们偶尔被允许接受家属探视。他的母亲给他带了一个便盆。她从商店买了一个便盆并带了过去，因为他说这是他唯一想要的东西，能让他的生活好过一些。但看守不肯给他。直到有一天看守们举行派对，他们才最终答应给他。穆希卡大吵大闹，尖叫、哭泣并大喊着要他的便盆，他们最终才把它拿给他。
And he insisted on taking it with him whenever they moved him to a new cell or a new prison or anything like this. He saw it as a sign of his victory over the Jays, but he also refused to clean it, which I think is a – so he had sort of been driven half mad. Anyway, he, Mujica, was released in 1985, and he wanted to still be involved in politics. He sort of moved slightly towards the more pragmatic center.
每当他们把他转移到新的牢房、新的监狱或类似地方时，他都坚持随身带着它。他认为这是他战胜看守的标志，但他也拒绝清洗它，我认为这是——所以他当时有点被折磨得半疯了。无论如何，穆希卡于1985年获释，他仍然想参与政治。他有点转向了更为务实的中间派。
He was still left wing, but he wasn't a Tupomaros anymore, or a member of the Tupomaros. Anyway, the people who had tortured him and kept him in prison and all this sort of stuff, in 2009, the Uruguayan people voted on a law to give them amnesty, to have an amnesty for everybody who had been involved in state repression. And the law passed.
他依然是左翼，但不再是图帕马罗斯成员了。不管怎样，那些折磨他、把他关在监狱里以及诸如此类事情的人，在2009年，乌拉圭人民投票通过了一项法律，给予他们大赦，对所有参与国家镇压的人实行大赦。该法案通过了。
It was basically a referendum and the Uruguayan people approved it. So that's, you know, you would say for Mujica, quite bad. But on the very same day, they picked him to be the president of Uruguay. And he was the president of Uruguay from 2010 to 2015. He was an extraordinary figure by the standards of world leaders.
这基本上是一场公投，乌拉圭人民批准了它。所以，你可以说这对穆希卡来说相当糟糕。但就在同一天，他们选他担任乌拉圭总统。他在2010年至2015年期间担任乌拉圭总统。按世界领导人的标准来看，他是一个非凡的人物。
So he was a former urban guerrilla. And he was married to a fellow urban guerrilla called Lucia. They didn't have any children. They lived in a farm on the outskirts of Montevideo where they cultivated chrysanthemums for sale. So a chrysanthemum farm. That was basically their job. When he became president, he refused to move into the presidential palace. Why was he chosen as president?
他曾是一名城市游击队员。他和一个同为城市游击队员名叫露西亚的女性结了婚。他们没有孩子。他们住在蒙得维的亚郊外的一个农场里，在那里种植菊花出售。所以是一个菊花农场。这基本上就是他们的工作。当他成为总统时，他拒绝搬进总统府。他为什么会被选为总统？
He didn't run for it. He just got... He did run for it. Yeah, he did run for it. He ran as a sort of left-wing maverick, I suppose. But it's a symbol of humility and frugality because they lived on this farm with a dog with three legs called Manuela. He drove a 1987 Volkswagen Beetle.
他并没有竞选。他只是得到了……他确实竞选了。是的，他确实竞选了。我想他是作为某种左翼特立独行者参选的。但这象征着谦逊和节俭，因为他们和一只名叫曼努埃拉的三条腿的狗住在农场里。他开着一辆1987年的大众甲壳虫。
He refused to use the state limousines and all this kind of stuff. He was paid $12,000, American dollars a month, 90% of which he gave to charity, or refused to take any of it for himself. And he presided over a very, very liberal regime, so people would say, of Uruguay in the last few years. It had the world's most sort of liberal government. So legalized abortion, legalized cannabis, gay marriage. But anyway, yes, so he retired in 2015.
他拒绝使用国宾车之类的东西。他的月薪是12,000美元，其中90%他都捐给了慈善机构，或者自己分文不取。在他执政期间，乌拉圭迎来了一个非常非常自由主义的政权，人们会这么说。它拥有世界上最自由主义的政府。因此，堕胎合法化、大麻合法化、同性婚姻合法化。不管怎样，是的，他在2015年退休了。
He's still alive, 87 years old. Doesn't spend his time, I imagine, in a horse trough, but is back on his farm cultivating his chrysanthemums. Does he still have his potty? I don't know about the potty. I feel like if I did meet him, that's not what I would ask. It would be tasteless to ask, Tom. It would be insensitive to ask.
他现在还活着，87岁。我想他现在不会把时间花在马槽里了，而是回到了他的农场里种植他的菊花。他还有他的便盆吗？我不知道便盆的事。我觉得如果我真的见到他，我不会问那个。问那个会显得没品。问那个会很不体面。
No, that's a great story and a great end. And Dominic, you pulled it off so well that I'm going to allow you to play the pan pipes again to play to play us out tom that's lovely so that was uruguay do you feel educated now do you feel you know about uruguay i feel so educated and isn't that isn't that what this tour of the globe is all about it's a process of self-education for us oh isn't that as much as anything else yeah so that's the two primaris kind else. Yeah. So that's the Tupper Maros. Kind of a grim story. But let's hope that one day you too don't become a prisoner of the Tupper Maros. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening,
不，这是一个很棒的故事，也是一个很棒的结局。多米尼克，你讲得太棒了，所以我允许你再次吹响排箫来为我们送行。汤姆，这太美妙了。所以这就是乌拉圭，你现在觉得自己受过教育了吗？你觉得自己了解乌拉圭了吗？我觉得自己受到了极大的教育，这不正是这次全球之旅的意义所在吗？对我们来说，这是一个自我教育的过程。哦，这同样也是。是的，所以图帕马罗斯……差不多就是这样。是的，所以图帕马罗斯。有点残酷的故事。但愿有一天你也不会成为图帕马罗斯的囚犯。感谢收听《The Rest Is History》。如需获取独家单集、抢先收听、无广告收听
and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、少许八卦的固定去处，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想无广告收听、获取独家单集和现场门票的抢先购买权，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。